hey i'm gonna do everybody a big favor
right now
i'm not telling on anybody i'm not
telling you anybody that i know
[ __ ] crazy that's dry snitching
everybody get
oh yeah well this person that person
know all the people that know me
that i know hey i pay my homage to in
person
have to pay it on the [ __ ] camera
[ __ ] is wrong
that [ __ ] off
all right sure one and only welcome back
took you a second hunter you you looked
for me high and low man you kept
bothering me
yeah i did you did man you wouldn't
leave me to [ __ ] alone yeah i thought
you were interesting the first time
around
yeah that's what made me like you too
though man you was persistent like
myself i don't give up
neither do i that make us blood brothers
from detroit yeah
yeah so we we talk on the phone
sometimes
we have some we've had some interesting
conversations recently the the talk
about uh
you you live in vegas yeah and the you
got to we got into a conversation about
this homeless woman that you met in the
store
you know man before i get into that
i really feel like
people treat people really shitty man
and it's not people like myself who are
in the game or
people who even inspire being in the
game
i've just watched your average joe blow
laugh at a woman that was hungry she was
crying man i walk you know
i walk to the store in the morning
sometimes man sometimes i slow down and
i can uh
i can really see things for what it is
you know i always call myself hey not
missing nothing so in the mornings you
know i slow down
i take me a stroll to the store and this
one particular morning i walk in
and i uh i see i didn't even notice her
man because i'm just in my own zone i'm
just walking in i know what i'm getting
i'm a simple person i get the same thing
every time
i don't change i don't get anything else
you know what i'm saying mark
you know what the [ __ ] i'm saying
martial okay then there we go come on
stay with me
so we in the i'm in the store i walk in
and as i grab what i need to grab i come
and i stand in the line it's
it's a little long line you know unusual
for in the mornings but uh i walk in
there i'm walking
i stand in the line and i just hear this
lady just scream she just screams out of
nowhere man
and i look up and it's this is this is
i'm saying this caucasian lady man is
short hair dirty man dirty dirty
dirty don't look like she took a bath
man for months
for months she was black
at this point she wasn't even wasn't
even dirt it's just blackness
you know she was standing there and uh
my first move was you know i brought my
i brought some cards on me so i didn't
have much cash and they got like five
six singles on me
ran up to the front of the stores just
in me man i ran up to the front of the
store
gave her the five six singles as they
were kicking her out because she yelled
you know they didn't like that outburst
but i noticed there was somebody that
was standing in front of the line
that was with me that when she yelled he
kind of chuckled
kind of laughed at her i thought it was
funny
you know this woman was in here pretty
much crying
she wasn't just begging she was crying
pleading
just somebody just show some type of
compassion
you know i run up there i give her five
six dollars whatever i could do and
i come back to the line and it just i
just couldn't [ __ ] get it out of my
mind that this man
in front of me that calls himself a man
decided to laugh at this woman
you know i must have told him i said you
know man you're a real piece of [ __ ]
that you know and all of you in this
store i said it loud
told every [ __ ] body in that store i
said all of you were pieces of [ __ ]
because you'd rather sit there and laugh
at that woman than help that woman
it bothered me so much man i went to the
back i don't eat the [ __ ] from no
[ __ ] corner store no gas station
i went to the back i found a deli
sandwich uh grabbed her some lace potato
chips a [ __ ] big tall aquafina water
you know
it's one of the cheapest ones but it's
something it's anything
i went up there i paid for what i could
pay for i grabbed it and as i ran
outside she was walking up the block
and uh you'll say i called for i said
hey she came back up
and uh i was like here you know what i
ain't got much i said but i know you
hungry
you know i pull out the bag i pull the
sandwich out i pull the chips out
pull the water out i asked her i could
tell she's smoking on a dirty ass
newport 100.
and i could tell she picked it up from
somewhere she ain't
just have a pack on her you know what i
mean so i was like hey
you want you want some cigarettes you
got some frostbite i'm saying i smoke
cools you know so i'm
it probably ain't what she smokes but
nonetheless
you know you need some cigarettes i give
her five six cigarettes
and she's like yeah thank you thank you
thank you thank you so much
and you know she goes to start to walk
off and you know i can tell the store on
her whatever you know the manager come
outside just to kind of come
see like you know they don't like you
helping people i notice they don't like
you helping people that are around the
stores and
things like that so you know she starts
she starts to walk off
and i i call her i say hey
and she turns around and i just wanted
her to know i told her i said hey
i just want you to know that i love you
like i really love you and we gonna get
through this
and she started crying and i don't care
about no [ __ ] [ __ ] covert i've been
walking through
the slums of this [ __ ] all my life so
to me i walked if i gave her a hug she
was crying she's a woman that's crying
man it was
hurting
i couldn't stand and watch that man
you know pimps and gangsters and drug
dealers you know
back in the beginning of the time
we were the people that helped the
community
you know when the government didn't want
to help you know when nobody wanted to
come down and help man
we were the ones that's the error that i
come from
that's what i remember as well you know
what i'm saying i noticed man i could be
on the freeway
traffic's held up i'm not sure about the
drug dealers but the pimps for sure
pimps drug dealers i've known them all
i've had people like that when i was
younger help me along the way
all walks of life that called themselves
a part of any type of game
any part of entity i'm not going to
leave them out whether they would
probably leave my profession out
or who i am they'd probably leave that
out today or they don't want to mention
us they want to away with us but you
know what
i i respect them i respect them for what
they do
whether i understand it or not doesn't
matter i respect it
it's what's kept us going
what do you make of these new like i've
done a figure figure
figueroa quite a bit lately and these
tennis shoe temps that that exists now
the game has changed so much what do you
make of these guys
get your weather together get your
weather together
get your weather together
you shouldn't have your [ __ ] out here
man and some [ __ ] what's them them
[ __ ] them slide on
puff shoes with the little back the
little uggs seen a [ __ ] out there when
she didn't have ugg
she had uss said what type of [ __ ] is
this
i had to ask her matter of fact i was
out on fig man i got picked up man i
came
straight from the airport man my partner
picked me up
first place we hit a figaro
go down figaro man i seen one of the
girls man
that was out there oh yo on your on this
soft white underbelly
oh you're talking about the girl yeah
yeah i don't know her name i know she
was saying she
she was standing there and i said hey
baby come back around here
and she was just so angry
she was just so upset
you know and i didn't really uh
i didn't really know how to tell i was
like becca why are you so mad
i had to tell her hey i love you even
though i didn't
but she she needed somebody to tell her
something because she was angry
listen i say this all the time i even
tell this to people that when i'm
i'm at a girl i could be at a grocery
store i could be in a mall i could be
anywhere and i'm sitting there and i'm
getting customer service and the
customer service just seems shitty
if you don't like your job quit
why do something that you don't love
i will never ever understand that
no one can ever make me so the girls
that work for you tend to like what they
do
it's not about what anybody does it
works for me mark
no it's not what we're that's that's not
fair it works for them they enjoy what
they do
you would have to i don't even live like
that
i only do things that i love to do
don't do something to just keep me going
i mean people are out there right now
they know this watching this
just doing [ __ ] to keep you going stop
stop stop while you're behind
cause you're damn sure not ahead
so tennis shoe pimps you didn't answer
the question what do you think of these
new the new the new breed of town
they're basically just you need to quit
they're just drunk you
need they need to get their weather
together it is what i just told you mark
they need to get their weather together
is this right listen if you're gonna do
it
just tighten up baby i'm not a person
that's gonna sit there and knock you if
you're gonna be in it be in it for real
stop perpetrating to being something
that you know that you're not
it wasn't us that ruined the game
it was people allowing squares into our
bubble
because the older style pimps were
almost uh community leaders we were
listen to me man this used to be a
secret society man
secret society and it wasn't a lot of us
it wasn't a lot of us mark you couldn't
there's [ __ ] 400 of them over here in
this state 400 of them over here in this
state no you had a couple and everybody
knew who everybody was
so i'm not here to talk about no names
and call no i know who i know and they
know me and i know some of the greats i
want to name off no names
because i've really been with them times
when the cameras go dark
and the curtains close man i've been
with some of the best
we're going to get this [ __ ] out today
we ain't leaving until we do this
so is only fans a threat to the uh to
your i don't think so
i don't think so i'm not against
anything
listen to me man i'm i'm a man that that
loves sex
i love sex i love everything about it i
love everything of
what it does what it attends to i have
nothing against and only
fans hey if it's gonna if it's gonna be
lucrative
let it be lucrative i'm i'm
i'm hey not against it at all
at all i have nothing against only fans
only fans just
i just noticed that it starts bringing
everybody about you know you got people
that say that they would never do it
before having only fans well guess what
it's a gateway so if you're calling
yourself not trying to be a part of the
game or calling yourself
it's a stepping stone to hauling so stop
that's not what you want to be
considered you know it kills me man
it [ __ ] kills me mark you ever notice
a [ __ ] can go out and [ __ ] [ __ ] tom
ralph [ __ ] michael not even wiper
[ __ ] and go back home and kiss her man
you offer her some money for it she's
[ __ ] appalled
how dare you how dare you there you
offer me some i'm a lady
no you're not yeah no you're not
no you're not stop
stop disrespecting real ones that are in
the game
to the to the ladies of the night
i want you to know that i respect you
it's not a lot of us left none of us
from men to women it's not a lot of us
left but i want you to know that i
respect you
and i cherish what y'all do and if you
gotta hold your money and save it till
you can give it to somebody real
do it don't play yourself no more
save your money put in the pillowcase
put it in the [ __ ] ground i don't
give a [ __ ] what you do with it but
don't give it to these suckers
stop giving it to these suckers man
what makes you tick what do you get
excited about
money no i'm just playing man
no it is the money but neither here
there is
it's my kids it's my living everyday
life
why do they think that that pimps
hustlers or
anybody that even lives like that why do
they think that we stop
living like that like everything is
grimy i pay my [ __ ] taxes too
i love paying my taxes and what do you
say is your occupation on your tax
return
entertainers consultant very good
sharp productions uh they sent it to me
in various forms
and you pay some taxes yes good for you
pay my taxes
i pay you got to i don't want them
people at my doorstep
not even not even the least bit you got
to
man it's 20 20 we living in
what do you know now that you wish you
knew when you were younger
how to be more patient
how to take my time a little bit more
with things the only time anything's
ever
happened to me in a [ __ ] up sense or
in a way
was only when i got greedy it was only
when i got greedy
it was never because i just said hey i'm
i'm having enough a i'm out it's always
because i got greedy
i'm i'm gonna i'm a i'm a standard
american we're all greedy
mark we're all greedy
all of us and nobody's hands are clean
i'm just one of the people that don't
mind coming in sharing my side of
dirty hands how do you define
success
being who you really are and i don't
think that has anything to do with the
money
being who you really are who you're
happy with
i've said it before not and even in the
game you know i say not
with the next man thing so the next
woman thinks no it's about you
it's about you
they stand out here and they listen they
want to know what i got to say
they out there waiting
you can't listen to me you can't mimic
the real
you know you know what i was i was i was
thinking about the other day man you
notice how like you always
i notice you'll buy people christmas
dinner and thanksgiving dinner and
things like that right
do you know that the average american
the average american throws away 20 and
this is this is the average american
home a family throws away
20 pounds of food a month
in every american home 20 pounds of food
man
you got people out here been ain't for
days
for days mark for days
but they knock people like me and i'm
the only one that's coming out here even
really trying to help
even when i'm moving and grooving man
they look at me godly like
man i wanna
i've had people tell me man i'll kiss
your shoes
you ain't gotta do all that man i
wouldn't even make somebody i don't give
a [ __ ]
what you got going on i would never make
you degrade yourself like that
ever in my life
take what you need and god bless you
gotta kiss my [ __ ] feet
people don't know what it's really like
man
for somebody who lives in every day
toe-to-toe
whether it's in a physical
movement or just a shitty state of mind
what's the biggest misconception about
you your personality is very big
that i'm passionate but they take it as
aggression what happened to people
really
having a passion i care about what i
believe in it's like a religion
everybody's got one it's like a religion
i believe in what i believe in don't
have to tell
you anything or have to convince you
people out in the world that want to
watch it
and to convince you nothing i'm gonna be
who i
am regardless to the fact
that you want to say this is bad or it's
bad profession or
this is what man stall the [ __ ]
and kill that [ __ ] cause i really don't
give a [ __ ]
i really don't not about anything that
you want to tell me that i could have
been doing or should have been doing i
don't care about none of that [ __ ] that
it's not me that doesn't make sharp
would you say earlier tick
just getting around to answering it for
you you know what i'm saying it's not
what makes sharp tick man
make a sharp tick is being real and to
me
real is reality
this is my reality man yeah i found it
interesting that uh
there were some comments on your first
video saying that you were fake
but we we should have mentioned that you
were named pimp of the year
a few years ago at the uh player's ball
i'm [ __ ] man i've won
trophies as far back as oh saturday
so you're for real 2007. yeah
what year are we in now what are we
headed to 2021 soon
well my first one man 2007.
i've always won prestigious things you
know
and you know that's not for the average
mind to understand we don't invite you
people so you don't have to really worry
about it
you know we don't invite you we don't
ask you to come and
come attend there's a lot of experts in
the comments oh my god i noticed
everybody's got something to say that
doesn't know anything about it they
don't know anything
it's always the person with the least
you know the the pimp
world is such a wide there's such a wide
range of uh from the top to the bottom
there's there's guys like kenny red
and the bishop and guys like myself
and yourself and then you've got the
skid row pimps or the or the tennis shoe
pimps on figueroa
who are just basically drug dealers that
that
have girlfriends that they're hosting i
say this remember when i said that uh
i got stuck in a time and you ever got
stuck in a time that you
you didn't want to leave well i'm happy
and blessed to say i got stuck in one of
the realest times
because at the time where i got stuck it
was one of the realest times
of being this now everybody's just doing
it man to
get by so let's pay the room we got to
pay the room for the day get a sack
might be able to get you an outfit
i think you're easy to misread because
your your voice your presentation
is very um i'm passionate it comes off
as aggressive i'm passionate
not combative but i find you to be one
of the kindest and most compassionate
people i know i mean you said to me
when you saw me today uh thank you for
being alive the same time
i'm alive who says that i appreciate you
for everything
it's beautiful i appreciate you for
everything no one's ever said that to me
really never it's beautiful well guess
what mark we're gonna say it again for
the record
i am happy to be alive the same time
that you are and i love you brother
likewise for sure hopefully you know
we could do more in the future you know
i'm not i'm not always available
you know and uh
but if you ever want to reach out to me
man you ever want to you know
talk like this again and we can we can
you know what i'm saying we can just
give give our insight together you know
i'll come to you next time
come to me next time we're gonna sit in
the backyard we're gonna do this one
next to the pool
yeah man we gonna do this everybody
always thinks that man is
he lives on skid row why the [ __ ] do i
live on skid row why would you
why would they even think that i've
never been to skid row until
i brought you i've been to skid row i've
just never lived on it
yeah i've been a skid row been through
skid row many times
i've watched people that i know get in a
bad way i didn't even [ __ ] understand
and land on skid row
how'd you fall that week to the knee but
you know what that's not my life that's
not my
journey to sit there and speak on all
i'm gonna say is is this if you're gonna
be
in this game do it for real
when i came up in it it was for real
hell we used to turn las vegas boulevard
into sunset
back then it's like [ __ ] look like
[ __ ] football players man
moving through cars weaving through
traffic sweating [ __ ]
i swear man it was a beautiful thing the
most that you know
today you can't even look like you do
something like this
back in the day when i was coming up man
the most that the police would ever say
they would see you sweating some game
just sweating them friendly sweating
doing your
job most police would say was hey man
hey he's up on the prostitutes guys oh
my intercom
wouldn't stop wouldn't [ __ ] bring all
this extra [ __ ] and
and controversy into the mix these are
not pimps
i'm going to say that right now
these are not pimps
and i don't i don't knock anybody but
it's [ __ ] up when you [ __ ] go and
get somebody else that ain't in this
game
and expect him to act accordingly to it
how could he ever accept you
he's not me it's not the
some of the people that i know
my roots run deep man
to this [ __ ] and we can get into that
one another time
this isn't no game haven't i showed you
and we ain't got a show we ain't got to
show financial
nothing me and you both know am i right
mark you
you've seen it with me right i've seen
what you carry
we're okay we're gonna be okay man
us together i got a couple questions for
you mark
[ __ ] it let's let's get into it i got a
couple questions for you
what do you want to know you say uh
you'd be out on a you you'd be out on
figaro late at night have you ever paid
one of them out there for sex
no i have not i've never paid for sex
not one time
never not one time out on figaro never
no i mean i look like it because i'm
picking girls up on the street and i'm
driving them away and i bring them over
here and uh
there's no bed here but uh yeah but i
bring them back and i don't know what
that looks like but
but i know what it is you know what it
is but ain't it always what it looks
like
ain't that what they care about it's
always what it looks like [ __ ]
they care about what this looks like
right now yeah i don't care
and you know what that's why i don't
care i think for myself and that's why i
don't care
i don't care about anything for myself
and that's why i want the viewers to
know
this shit's [ __ ] up the game these
tennis shoes these tennis shoe pimps
sending these girls out here for 40
50 dollars robbing people putting things
in their
drinks what's wrong with you man that is
not the game we are supposed to be
gentlemen of leisure not
gentlemen of hey well i claim this
neighborhood and then you know
i'm gonna put my pimping down for a
second or i'm putting my ism down for a
second or i'm gonna put my hustle down
for a second yo
money you gonna put your money down for
a second to deal with this nigel
no he's smarter than that man
to all my people out there man be
smarter than that
let's re inve let's read let's revamp
what really took took place in this game
man
let's really revamp that the old-school
ways everybody says they have the i've
noticed that it almost looks like it's
divisions everybody wants to move and
oh they believe this way they believe
it's supposed to go this way over here
they believe it's supposed to go this
way over there they believe it's
supposed to man homie
it's only one way church it's only one
way
i've been doing it for 18 years man
18 [ __ ] years
it's only one way
and that's the right way man
you dig that's the right way
i got one more question for you though
mark i don't like how to turn back
on me man it's fun are you are you my
friend for real
i think i am are you really my friend i
think i am yes so you know you can't
manipulate me right
ever anybody ever i don't manipulate
anybody ever
ever can never ever you would not be
very easy to manipulate
yeah i don't think so either but that's
not my thing
okay just making sure just let just
letting you know mark
everybody thought i had a problem with
you last time i noticed everybody
thought i had a
i didn't get that i didn't get that
either we're the best of friends right
always have been always have been
everybody that comes in here from
detroit especially
i connect with i feel a connection with
anybody from detroit
i was like i said man i was just uh in
chicago i was i was born i lived in
chicago man
lived in chicago chicago crazy place
it's a [ __ ] crazy place man i was
back there i was back there a while
back man [ __ ] man i didn't did it all up
and down state street [ __ ] i don't even
bought a
first from you know miss diane on oak
street she's what she used to have a
little she's having first shop over
there off oak street
i remember seeing it huh yeah i just
messed with her you need a fur coat
yeah it was cold i remember coming from
the west coast man back then
and [ __ ] this is in march and i come in
man you know i'm
i'm dressed for uh west coast i'm saying
west coast attire
you know i'm i made some man that
[ __ ] air come through howling through
them big ass
buildings that [ __ ] ain't no joke
actually ain't no joke out there man i
like chicago
chicago was cool man it's a great place
to come from yeah
yeah great place to grow up yeah it
seems like the whole world [ __ ] up
today ain't it
yeah it's been a rough year yeah it's
coming
what do you think the world needs now
a leader like me shark for president
[Laughter]
no man you know honestly all jokes aside
man
i i really feel like we're [ __ ] either
way it doesn't matter who we vote for
and that's honest that's that's my
honest opinion man it doesn't matter
it's going to go bad either way it's
going to go sour
they're already ready for it to go sour
how is it that man we we have all we
we're the strongest we're the most
powerfulest country in the world
from american government american
pimp american hustler american
con artist american whatever we are the
best of the best
we are the best of the best at what we
do
over here and i like every other country
it's just
[ __ ] up to watch all my people out
here hurting man i'm only one man i
can't help them all i try
but i can't help them all mark i can't
help them all
i think that we need to do a better job
man within this system
and stop giving people [ __ ] ass
programs
and thinking that's what's going to give
get them an out out of here and out of a
[ __ ] 10.
that's the problem man they think oh
program is going to fix everything
oh put them in a program program program
assessment test assessment assessment
test
who's that one girl man i felt real bad
for her man
who was that the girl uh lynne
was that her name you brought her on a
few times
you know man it was something that
resonated with me because you know i'm
out here man
i i know how people think how we're
moving especially in
in a dark world she had said something
along the lines she was like
i just she says i just want to [ __ ]
die
see her mind was already dead spirit was
already dead
she was just waiting on her body to
catch up
that's all it is a lot of these people
out here man right now just waiting on
their body to
rot right along with a soul and with
their mind and the government man the
city
[ __ ] city of los angeles will watch
this they put [ __ ] cops on the corner
you hear them
they rather harass people than [ __ ]
help people
you hear that sirens and hey hey where
the man is that what you doing out here
you know what these people out here
doing
you watch them every day
it's a problem out here mark
this war with the government how's the
people of the
of the united states at war with its own
government
this shit's sad man but they want to
knock people like me
knock what i do i watch the news just
like everybody else does
oh what because i decided to get my
money a little bit differently or i've
done things a little bit differently
who [ __ ] gives a [ __ ]
i'm the same like you mark the same like
all these viewers
it doesn't change
that doesn't determine me or define me
this is me man
whether i i choose to stop tomorrow or
not it doesn't [ __ ] matter and it's
nobody's concern who's watching this you
can suck my balls
through the drawers and you remember
that i said that and i
mean that from the bottom of my heart
this
evil face that you say i'm aggressive or
i'm a
no i just stand up for me a lot of [ __ ]
you people don't do these days
but we're americans right land of the
free
why can't i [ __ ] freely exercise my
right
to keep it ism
why they want to take us down mark
run us in the ground 300 years 400 years
they're [ __ ] handing out
[ __ ] slave years
now i'm a person that don't condone man
[ __ ] with babies or anything even
with teen in it i don't like it
that's me i don't like anything with
teen in it
i've always dealt with grown-ups we all
make our own choices
everything is by choice
everything is by choice man nobody's
here to force
anybody into anything
whether they want to believe that or not
think that i'm out here oh he's he's
hurt no
i already said i don't want to be the
gorilla i'm not the gorilla
i don't even like bananas
i'm dead ass serious
this shit's bigger than me let's point
the finger at the people that's really
the trouble man because it damn sharing
me
or any colleague that i know anybody
i've ever known that's ever done
something like this
anything it's not us man
it's them
they consider us the circus we consider
them the [ __ ] zoo
as much as they watch and laugh at us we
sit back and we laugh just as hard
everybody always want to know what's in
my cup you'll never know
champagne
yeah so you think
well sharp thank you for coming in again
interesting as always
as always i hope we do many more of
these i love you all
church
yeah give it to one us around this
[ __ ] sure yeah we real ones
around here believe that jack all them
comments and [ __ ] we ain't worried about
that we in them streets
come see us where they get famous sat on
that [ __ ] blade but guess what
i'ma say this you won't